on va passer à des questions
personnelles meyrin trop passive ouvert
quelle est la fréquence de vos rapports
sexuels quel est le nombre moyen de
contact physique avec votre compagne
50-54 ans ça me paraît trop quand même
50 6 1 6 4 5 6 vous allez tester une
molécule devra prendre un comprimé tous
les matins et dans la foulée vous
étreindre pendant une dizaine de
secondes nous étreindre c'est à dire
[Musique]
quelque chose pour le premier trimestre
et des bonnes raisons d'être malheureux
basse pas notre cas
pensé comme des gorets qui nous
permettent de mieux voir c'est pas
d'autres sentiments c'est le même mais
en plus nette victoire cousin comment
arthur et donc pour la suite du coup et
a pas de suite la suite du traitement
c'est fini ça peut arriver que le
patient en fin de test ressenti sorte
d'abord où donc tu veux arrêter dissiper
me reprenne le très pop
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
savate on va pas aller cambrioler un
laboratoire
pourquoi ce titre en français mais
normalement on n'a peut-être pas besoin
de ça
[Musique]